die sollten und der wagnertruppe lange
galten sie als Putins Schattenarmee die
weltweit die Ziele des kremmels
durchsetzten berüchtigt für Folter
Vergewaltigungen und Kriegsverbrechen
seitdem russischen Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine sind Wagner Truppen und ihr Chef
Jewgeni prigorcin allgegenwärtig sie
haben 50.000 kriminelle in Gefängnissen
rekrutiert und kämpfen an vaterster
Front wie hier in bachmut ausgerechnet
diese Truppe bricht mit dem Kreml für
Putin sind sie Verräter
sie versuchen einen Aufstand zu
organisieren der das Land in Anarchie
und Brudermord treibt bis hin zu
Niederlage und Capitulation
am Samstag steht Russland kurz vor einem
Bürgerkrieg er fliegt sehr niedrig sagt
das Kind
[Musik]
in varonia beschießt die russische Armee
ein öldepot der Wagner Truppen und die
schießen zurück zu stören nach Angaben
russische militärblogger ein Flugzeug
und sechs Hubschrauber der russischen
Armee der wagnertruppe ist es ernst
wer versucht Widerstand zu leisten den
betrachten wir als Bedrohung den werden
wir umgehend vernichten
[Musik]
wagner-chef prigoschin kündigt am
Freitagabend einen Marsch der
Gerechtigkeit an der von Rostov am Don
über woronirsch nach Moskau führen soll
prigosh ihn gegen Putin ein Ringen um
die macht man kann das auch durchaus mit
einem Machtkampf in einer Mafia
ähnlichen Situation Organisation
beschreiben es geht hier nicht um einen
modernen Staat mit seinen Institutionen
sondern letztlich auch um verschiedene
Clans bewaffnete Clans darum wie stark
ist der Patronen ganz oben in der
Organisation noch welche Köpfe gibt es
da drunter die sozusagen aufsteigen
wollen die ihre Macht erweitern wollen
wie weit reicht denn die Macht von
Wladimir Putin noch über den Kreml
hinaus in diesem Moment offensichtlich
reichte sie für viele Stunden nicht bis
nach Rostock am Donner nicht bis nach
Baronessa nicht mal bis zur Autobahn vor
Moskau
nach Rostow steht da in Anlehnung an
nach Berlin im Zweiten Weltkrieg die
Wagner Truppen Sieges gewiss
den starb der russischen Armee in Rostow
am Don besetzt am Samstag Vormittag im
Spaziergang
er plaudert mit russischen Generälen die
in Wahrheit seine Geiseln sind auch das
eine Machtdemonstration und eine
Demütigung für Präsident Putin und der
Herrscher im Kreml ist besorgt und droht
diejenigen die man in dieses Verbrechen
hineinziehen will sollen bloß keine
tragischen Fehler begehen die man nicht
wieder gut machen kann sondern die
einzig richtige Wahl treffen die
kriminellen Handlung beenden
doch die Wagner Truppen ziehen
unbeeindruckt Richtung Moskau kaum
Widerstand der russischen Armee
die Armee hätte Möglichkeiten gehabt
dies zu stoppen und das wir Fragen auf
ob die Goschen mit seiner kritikername
der Korruption den Blutvergießen durch
sinnlose Angriffe mit all dem nicht
größere Resonanz gefunden hat in Teilen
der Streitkräfte die da sich zumindest
doch oft haben dass der Krieg
effizienter oder anders weitergeführt
wird wenn Erfolg hat
während Wagner Truppen 200 km vor Moskau
stehen wird die russische Propaganda
hilfloslos
wie unterbrechen unser Programm sagt der
Moderator des Staatsfernsehens die sonst
so aggressive Propaganda Maschine stockt
es werden Meldungen aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium vorgelesen
alles was brigochien von sich gebe sei
nicht wahr und eine so wirklich
informations Provokation
und TV-Moderator solawiof der
normalerweise lautstark gegen den Westen
hetzt meldet sich aus einem Auto und ist
sehr leise
der Feind ist dort
in der Ukraine gegen den ukrainischen
Narzissmus müssen wir kämpfen hört auf
bevor es zu spät ist wir verlieren sonst
unser Land es gibt nichts Schlimmeres
als Bürgerkrieg
doch prigoshi sieht sich im Recht und
erzählt von Verlusten an der Front
wir haben enorm viel Gelände verloren
und getötete Soldaten gibt es drei bis
viermal mehr als nach oben gemeldet wird
und die niedrigen Opferzahlen die nach
oben gemeldet werden sind im Fernsehen
dann noch viel niedriger wir haben bis
zu 1.000 Verluste am Tag tote
verschollene verletzte
das offen einzuräumen eine Provokation
und setzt Putin unter Druck dieser
gesamte Krieg ist für Putin schon seit
Monaten gefährlich denn wir wissen auch
wiederum dass mit russischen Herrschern
die Kriege verlieren das denen kein
gutes Schicksal beschieden war da kann
man 1917 denken an den Zaren man kann
aber auch an z.B Michael Gorbatschow
denken der 1989 den Afghanistan Feldzug
verloren hat Rückblick gegen den
sowjetischen Präsidenten Gorbatschow
wird zwei Jahre nach Ende des
Afghanistan Krieges geputzt
Boris Jelzin Präsident der Teil Republik
Russland beendet den Putsch und hält
Gorbatschow an der Macht doch kein
halbes Jahr später zerfällt die UdSSR
[Musik]
zurück zu Priorin er bricht seinen
Putschversuch ab und erhält dafür
Straffreiheit auch seine Truppen die am
Samstag schätzungen zufolge fast 30
russische Soldaten töteten bleiben
straffrei und denkbar in einem
Rechtsstaat der Putsch ist vorbei doch
Putins macht wackelt ich glaube das ist
sehr ernst denn wir wissen dass nach so
einem Putsch die Dinge ins Rutschen
kommen können das heißt wir kommen
Prozesse in Gang eben diese Loyalitäten
werden aufgeweicht Leute fangen an auf
eigene Rechnungen Politik zu machen und
ich denke das werden wir auch hier sehen
[Applaus]
diese Bilder zeigen dass ich mit dem
vergangenen Samstag etwas verändert hat
in Russland die Menschen bejubeln die
wagnertruppen also erklärte Gegner des
Krems das sind die Bilder die Putin und
seine Helfer beunruhigen dürften
im Kreml bedankte sich Putin heute bei
seinen Geheimdiensten und bei der Armee
dass sie den Putsch gestoppt hätten und
räumt ein russland habe am Abgrund
gestanden
sie haben die verfassungsmäßige Ordnung
das Leben die Sicherheit und die
Freiheit unserer Bürger verteidigt
unsere Heimat vor Erschütterungen
bewahrt faktisch ein Bürgerkrieg
verhindert
dafür hat Putin teuer bezahlt er musste
mit einem Verräter verhandeln um an der
Macht zu bleiben bis Samstag war das
undenkbar